notre édition spéciale consacrée au
premier anniversaire du second
quinquennat Macron continue va se
projeter maintenant dans l'avenir sur
ces quatre prochaines années à l'Elysées
d'abord on revient sur cette situation
de blocage dont il n'a jamais pu sortir
l'absence de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale Mathias nous
replonge dans les trois premiers mois de
Macron de
100 jours pour un pulser un quinquennat
sous la 5e République cette période
pendant laquelle le chef de l'État est
en état de grâce dicte généralement le
style du reste du mandat alors il
nous revient
et relever les défis qui nous attendent
les années à venir à coup sûr
ne seront pas tranquilles après sa
réélection Emmanuel Macron se distingue
par sa lenteur lui le disruptif met 22
jours avant de nommer Elisabeth borne à
Matignon ensemble il leur faudra quatre
jours pour s'accorder sur un
gouvernement le travail continue de
manière sérieuse mais ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas une chose légère elle requiert
du temps des échanges de fonds et c'est
ce que la première ministre et moi-même
faisons donc autant de temps qu'utile et
que nécessaire car il s'agit du
gouvernement de la France
le remaniement fait le président de la
République referme une parenthèse de
politique nationale pour retrouver la
scène internationale entre la présidence
française du Conseil de l'UE et la
guerre en Ukraine dans l'entre-deux
tours des législatives avant de
s'envoler pour Kiev Emmanuel Macron
décide finalement de s'engager là encore
il n'a que peu de temps à consacrer au
dossier
les difficultés qui se sont exprimées
et je respecte
mais parce qu'il en va de l'intérêt
supérieur de la nation je veux
aujourd'hui vous convaincre de donner
dimanche
une majorité solide au pays un service
minimum sanctionné la majorité
présidentielle perd pratiquement sans
députés et n'est plus que relative
l'exécutif contraint cherche des
alliances sans succès la première
ministre m'a rendu compte vendredi du
résultat des consultations conduisent la
semaine dernière
il convient de prendre acte de l'absence
de volonté du parti du gouvernement de
participer à un accord de gouvernement
100 jours conclu sans projet majeur sans
vision claire et un président qui
attendra la rentrée pour lancer sa
nouvelle méthode démocratique le Conseil
national de la refondation
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce second débat Ludovic
vigogne bonsoir Manu vous êtes
journaliste à l'opinion et auteur de ce
livre les 100 jours Macron les secrets
d'un passage à vide publié chez bouquin
éditions
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes professeur
de sciences politiques à l'Université
Paris 1 Panthéon Sorbonne et Mathilde
Serrault évidemment est resté à mes
côtés Ludovic Vigan c'est 100 jours là
c'est son premier jour du second mandat
c'est ce que vous racontez dans notre
livre 100 jours SAS c'est le titre c'est
quoi c'est comme un vide comme un blanc
tout à fait il y a c'est un passage à
vide c'est un homme qui réussit un
exploit un président qui réussit à être
élu qui alors qu'il avait la majorité
absolue contrairement à François
Mitterrand 88 et à Jacques Chirac en
et en même temps un homme qui traverse
un passage à vide en prenant des
décisions stratégiques qui se révéleront
extrêmement mauvaise en parvenant pas à
nommer la première ministre qui n'a
initialement choisi on se voyant refuser
par les Français une majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale alors qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne doutait pas une seule seconde
qu'il obtiendrait facilement voilà c'est
un moment où le président prend des
décisions que ses proches de comprennent
pas ou son entourage des arçonnes comme
si il avait pas anticipé sa réélection
si vous diriez ça c'est sûr alors que
les sondages le le donne des vainqueurs
donc Emmanuel Macron pendant tout son
premier mandat a pensé chaque jour à sa
réélection il a pensé chaque jour
c'était son obsession et en fait il
s'est retrouvé le 24 avril et lui il
avait pas du tout anticipé préparait le
jour d'après et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
décide de prendre son temps de laisser
la poussière retomber il n'avait pas du
tout imaginé à la personne qui pourrait
la Matignon elle a à la configuration de
son gouvernement il se retrouve un peu
démuni dès le lendemain de son réalisme
en détail parce que c'est assez
passionnant un Charline business ce qui
est intéressant c'est que il y a en
germe dans ces trois premiers mois là
dont on parle d'Emmanuel Macron Macron 2
et en germe le blocage aujourd'hui ah
mais complètement d'autant qu'en fait on
lui reproche d'ailleurs beaucoup
aujourd'hui cette élection et cette
entre deux tours pourquoi et cette
campagne même cette non-campagne parce
qu'au fond on se rend compte qu'il y a
eu une espèce d'élection qui s'est faite
dans un mutisme complet alors on parle
beaucoup d'élections par défaut ça c'est
vrai qu'on a déjà dit en démocratie il y
a élection il y a pas élection mais au
fond on n'a pas eu de contenu
programmatique ni pour les législatives
ni pour les présidentielles et on a
surtout un président qui au fond alors
soit à jouer la trop grande certitude
sur justement sa personne en essayant de
cristalliser sur son bilan soit au
contraire a été très discret dans un
moment où on aurait pu attendre qu'il
soit justement présent alors on a dit
aussi que ça pouvait être un contraste
avec le premier mandat en se disant et
bien comme il avait été très présent et
qu'on avait un petit peu taxé
d'hyperprésidentialisme un peu comme à
la Nicolas Sarkozy ce premier mandat
macroniste le deuxième aura été celui de
la discrétion et c'était une manière
d'engager une rupture mais pourtant on
le verra quelques mois plus tard cette
nouvelle méthode n'est pas du tout
incarnée par une discrétion du président
de la République donc en fait il y a un
paradoxe inhérent à la deuxième élection
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'on est en train de
cristalliser et de vivre aujourd'hui et
puis donc deux mois après sa réélection
et là le 19 juin 2022 second tour des
législatives pas de majorité absolue bon
Frédéric savity est-ce que dans sa façon
de gouverner Emmanuel Macron il a tiré
les leçons de cet échec relativement
le mandat c'est que le président ne
pouvant pas être évidemment de nouveau
candidats forcément ça déclenche ça
s'était produit exactement de la même
façon avec François Mitterrand en 88 ça
déclenche immédiatement évidemment des
des luttes plus ou moins larvée pour la
succession et donc il était à la fois
avec un groupe réduit divisé
et très vite en fait le enfin voilà son
naturel est revenu au galop c'est à dire
qu'il a voulu à tout prix reprendre les
choses en main il a laissé peu de
latitude à sa première ministre quand il
y a une majoritaire relative dans une
dans un parlement quelle que soit le
régime par ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire bah il faut laisser du coup au
Premier ministre et le soin de négocier
en quelque sorte de mais là dans le
sujet mais dire ben on a essayé on n'a
pas réussi sauf que une semaine ça ne
suffit pas bah d'abord
il y a quand même effectivement une
erreur d'anticipation c'est-à-dire
la comparaison avec Mitterrand me semble
assez intéressante François mitter
anticipe le fait qu'il va devoir
élargir vers le centre d'ailleurs son
discours de campagne ça quand même c'est
l'ouverture bon la France unie voilà
donc il sent bien effectivement que on
va plus pouvoir faire une alliance avec
les mêmes et qu'il va falloir élargir et
donc il anticipe dans sa campagne ce que
ce que ce que Macron fait à certains
égards mais en allant quand même très
très sur la droite et en annonçant pas
d'emblée qu'il va éventuellement
proposer une alliance de gouvernement
avec une partie de des républicains et
donc du coup c'est vrai qu'ils se
retrouvent un petit peu surpris des
arçonnés alors comme il est quand même
élu aussi avec des voix de gauche et de
manière très décisive donc évidemment il
va hésiter alors qu'il voulait mettre
Martine Vautrin il va aller Catherine
votre Catherine pardon il va aller
chercher plutôt une première ministre
qui est plutôt marqué à gauche donc il y
a cette hésitation cette manque ce
manque d'anticipation et du coup après
évidemment cette espèce de
de de d'indécision dans l'isemment et
puis de reprise en main avec cette
réforme des retraites qu'il va à tout
prix faire passer comme s'il voulait
effectivement affirmer clairement une
autorité très personnelle alors que là
il fallait s'en servir d'une certaine
façon probablement pour le trait et le
trait d'image sur l'autorité ou
l'autoritarisme d'Emmanuel Macron on en
a parlé dans la première partie de cette
émission one qui est de plus en plus
marqué dans l'eau dans l'opinion vous
parliez de la méthode et on va se
replonger dans cette soirée du 24 avril
sur le Champ de Mars à Paris évidemment
donc Emmanuel Macron nous parle d'une
méthode refondée
mes chers compatriotes c'est avec
ambition et bienveillance pour notre
pays pour nous tous
que je veux pouvoir à vos côtés
aborder les cinq années qui viennent
cette terre nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode refondée pour cinq années de
mieux au service de notre pays
voyons souvent promises ça peut passer
par quoi si on essaye de se projeter
vers par exemple la réforme des
institutions ça fait partie des grands
chantiers qui nous a annoncé lundi soir
comment remettre de la démocratie
participative redonner un peu de souffle
à notre cinquième république fatigué ça
peut passer par quoi c'est ce qu'on peut
entendre derrière ce vocab de nouvelles
méthodes mais je crois qu'il faut
vraiment se méfier sous la Cinquième
République du nouveau en général la
Nouvelle Gauche les nouvelles alliances
etc en règle générale non non n'ont
donné qu'un espèce d'effet soufflé en
fait et qui sont retombées très vite et
je crois que on l'a dans le discours
d'investiture également ce mode nouvelle
méthode est apparu sans jamais
véritablement qu'on est les éléments
constitutifs de son ADN c'est-à-dire
est-ce que c'est une méthode justement
de concertation est-ce que c'est une
méthode de participation est-ce que tu
es une méthode de moins de président
tout simplement on aurait pu le penser
d'après les leçons qu'il entendait tirer
du premier mandat et pour autant en fait
on a on n'a jamais vraiment eu la
consistance de cette nouvelle méthode
alors on nous a parlé du CNR qu'on s'est
national de la refondation ou on était
censés faire un petit peu sans le
Parlement tout en étant dans le
délibératif mais au fond on voit bien
que cette nouvelle méthode ne peut pas
s'inscrire uniquement dans la création
de ce nouvel organe et donc
il est paradoxal d'entendre d'ailleurs
au 13 heures de la du dernière entretien
de d'Emmanuel Macron juste avant son
allocution qui l'inscrivait la réforme
des retraites dans cette nouvelle
méthode parce que pour lui il a concerté
auparavant donc est-ce qu'elle va avoir
une consistance nouvelle maintenant ou
est-ce que il date tout intérêt à
peut-être changer aussi de lexique moi
je crois en effet que le la nouvelle
méthode est un petit peu usé d'autant
qu'en plus les Français n'ont pas
forcément confiance dans ce concept un
petit peu vaseux donc je crois qu'il
serait peut-être temps de de l'inventer
mais peut-être en lui donnant un nouvel
habillage
le président n'a pas de majorité on le
sait on voit qu'il a quand même déjà et
ce qui s'est la volonté d'en passer par
une alliance par une coalition un peu
plus un peu plus solide notamment avec
la partie droite de l'échiquier
politique pourquoi ça bloque pourquoi ça
ne fonctionne pas et on voit ce statut
quoique et les lignes qui ne bougent pas
entre le camp de d'Emmanuel Macron et et
les républicains à droite d'opposition
que la parole se se déplace d'un invité
à l'autre parce que en fait je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne le veut pas
vraiment il n'est pas prêt à concéder
une once de pouvoir même s'il est dans
une situation extrêmement difficile il
se vit toujours comme celui qui devra
rendre des comptes à la fin et donc il
veut décider de tout il est pas décidé
il est pas du tout décidé à composer
donc il ne veut pas aller plus loin que
le projet par projet le cas par cas et
puis de l'autre côté il y a des
républicains qui sont extrêmement
divisés certains voudraient bien une
telle alliance mais la grande majorité
même si elle est un peu moindre qu'avant
ne veut pas une telle alliance ça
continue de se négocier ça de se
disputer avec ça il y a des échanges
évidemment entre entre députés Elisabeth
borne peut appeler parfois certains
responsables mais Emmanuel Macron n'a
jamais décroché son téléphone pour
proposer un entretien à erikioti à
l'Élysée ou le discuterait d'une feuille
de route alors peut-être ça peut venir
mais mais pour l'instant il a jamais
fait un téléphone et tant que c'est pas
lui qui le fait on peut pas voir le jour
il fallait que sa vie qui est-ce qu'on
peut compter sur Emmanuel Macron pour
faire une réforme de des institutions ah
alors ce qu'on en a besoin je pense tout
le monde est d'accord là-dessus il y a
eu plusieurs fois DVD qui ont été
abandonnés bon moi je pense par exemple
que quand en 2017 il propose une espèce
de ligne centriste pour la France et de
gauche et de droite une espèce de
troisième voie il fallait que derrière
plus évidemment une ambition de réformer
les pratiques politiques il la minima
derrière qu'il institut sinon tout ou
partie de l'élection des députés à la
proportionnelle parce que si vous voulez
faire exister effectivement un centre il
faut que le les mécanismes disons de
représentation favorise aussi
l'hébergence d'un centre et dans un
système qui est axé sur le majoritaire
de Tours forcément c'est ça bipolarise
bon voilà donc déjà là il y avait
évidemment à ce moment-là aussi une
carte à jouer probablement dans le
renforcement des corps intermédiaires il
y a le Macron a cessé de nous expliquer
qu'il fallait renouveler de la classe
politique et puis alors bon il y a bien
eu la convention citoyenne pour le
climat un moment mais dont il n'a pas
tiré
de conséquences pratiques il y a eu des
lois mais l'erreur je vais je vais je
vais tout reprendre et sans fil donc on
pouvait attendre quand même d'un
président comme ça qui venait une
société civile très particulière mais
quand même qui qui mettait en avant des
des des des
qui avait pas la même disons expérience
politique que d'autres on aurait pu
s'attendre quand même qu'il joue une
autre carte y compris avec des
organisations syndicales c'est très
bizarre quand même
son son comment dire ça non prise en
compte de la CFDT
d'emblée je parle en 2017 donc après
pour que les morceaux c'est assez
compliqué de la même façon qu'on aurait
pu imaginer qu'avec les élus locaux
une main soit on dit Macron se présente
libéral donc dans le libéralisme il y a
quand même la décentralisation il y a la
responsabilisation et là vis-à-vis des
Lycos c'est tout le contraire qui s'est
produit position très technocratique et
très centralise de on va reprendre en
main ses élus qui dépensent trop enfin
bon donc c'est vrai que après quand on
fait le compte de tout ça on arrive en
2022 c'est très très compliqué de de
revenir en arrière la confiance est très
difficile à établir avec tous ces
partenaires dont je vois pas très bien
comment aujourd'hui dans les 4 ans il
pourrait remettre tout ça à plat et se
transformer ce métamorphoser changer de
méthode moi j'y crois pas du tout c'est
à dire que voilà et puis pour mener une
telle
réforme des institutions évidemment
Emmanuel Macron il a besoin de qui du
président du Sénat proposa tam-train de
nous rejoindre de nouveaux sur ce
plateau rebonsoir table parce que depuis
2017 on peut dire que les relations
entre Emmanuel Macron et Gérard Larcher
non n'ont rien à long fleuve tranquille
oui lors du premier quinquennat Emmanuel
Macron dispose d'une majorité écrasante
à l'Assemblée le Sénat est vite vu bien
comme l'empêcheur de tourner en rond et
pourtant pourtant tout avait si bien
commencé on va voir quelques images
regardez Emmanuel Macron accueilli par
Gérard Larcher ici au Sénat il vient
pour la conférence des territoires il
fait des sermans d'amour au territoire
lors de son discours au Sénat en
présence du président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher et non les relations vont se
tendre rapidement avec les territoires
mais la rupture
avec le Sénat intervient bien sûr avec
l'affaire Benalla et la commission
d'enquête du Sénat alors Emmanuel Macron
appelle même personnellement Gérard
Larcher pour critiquer la tournure que
prend la commission d'enquête c'est
troupes crient au coup politique du
Sénat la suite on la connaît les
sénateurs le parquet pour faux
témoignage de trois collaborateurs de
l'Élysée dont Alexis colère proche parmi
les proches toujours secrétaire général
de l'Élysée les trois cas sont classés
sans suite mais la ligne est coupée
entre manuel Macron et Gérard Larcher et
ça va laisser des traces sur la la suite
du premier quinquennat et oui les
relations sont longtemps glaciales et
regardez ce que dit Gérard Larcher du
président de la République
il a une forme de rupture de confiance
avec une partie du pays le président
doit rassembler les Français jamais je
n'ai vu ce pays aussi divisé aussi
fracturé et moi j'ai envie plutôt
déclarerducteur de fracture qu'un
accélérateur de fracture voilà un
diagnostic encore aujourd'hui d'une
grande actualité mais de quand date
cette intervention et bien de janvier
2020 ça fait un an que les gilets jaunes
défilent chaque week-end et on sort d'un
mois de paralysie à cause de la réforme
de retraite la réforme des retraites
version numéro 1 celle qui voulait
construire un système universel des
retraites à l'époque Emmanuel Macron est
seul jupitérien quant au contraire gère
à l'archet veut lui montrer qu'il est
spécialiste de la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux d'ailleurs à
l'époque l'ancien ministre du Travail
reçoit chaque semaine des syndicats pour
parler de cette réforme et depuis il y a
eu un réchauffement ça date de quand il
y a lorsqu'Emmanuel Macron n'a eu qu'une
majorité relative donc voilà deuxième
quinquennat à l'Assemblée majorité
relative et donc est devenu une chambre
avec laquelle on peut négocier le
deuxième quinquennat c'est pas du tout
la même histoire genre Larcher là tout
de suite perçu racontez vous Ludovic
vigogne dans votre livre le président du
Sénat aurait dit en sortant de la
cérémonie d'investiture on éprouvait
physiquement qu'on était dans le
couchant voilà preuve que l'exécutif a
perdu de sa superbe dans ce contexte le
Sénat et du coup apparu comme un allié
les ministres ont retrouvé les numéros
des sénateurs les sénateurs ont voté de
nombreux textes notamment celui des
retraites et Gérard Larcher et bien
dernièrement a longuement échangé au
téléphone avec Emmanuel Macron mais par
exemple pour lui conseiller de mettre la
réforme de l'immigration sur pause et le
président de la République l'a écouté si
bien qu'aujourd'hui bien certains verrai
bien le président du Sénat prochain
Premier ministre et Gérard Larcher la
semaine dernière à mine de rien énoncé
ses conditions
pour gouverner il faut une majorité il
faut un projet vous voulez la majorité
contrat et aujourd'hui ces conditions ne
sont pas réunies ces conditions ne sont
pas réunies mais s'il vous le demande
est-ce que vous direz non
aujourd'hui je ne dirais pas oui voilà
bonjour je ne dirais pas oui mais demain
qui sait merci beaucoup tu es en train
de nu est-ce que vous y croyez Ludovic
vigogne un Gérard Larcher Premier
ministre aujourd'hui non dans l'état des
relations entre les deux hommes
aujourd'hui non je dis j'ai du mal à y
croire mais je ne l'exclut pas je trouve
que le démenti de Gérard Larcher est
effectivement assez mou on peut y lire
laissez-moi me faire réélire en
septembre au sénatorial laissez-moi me
faire élire président du Sénat et après
discutons
alors le président de la République a
fixé lundi dernier une échéance qui est
un petit peu avant les élections
sénatoriales c'est à dire le mois de le
14 juillet au terme de ces 100 jours
c'est ent mais bon est-ce qu'il ne va
pas plutôt attendre la rentrée pour voir
exactement
s'il peut vraiment nouer quelque chose
avec Gérard Larcher on va voir c'est
quoi le portrait robot Frédéric savity
selon vous du prochain Premier ministre
pour essayer parce que bon là on se
projette dans ce débat dans 4 ans de
encore quatre ans d'Emmanuel Macron
pourquoi faire pour continuer de
réformer comment continuer de réformer
aussi ne pas totalement exclure à un
moment un autre une dissolution de
l'Assemblée c'est pas on peut se
projeter dans 4 ans mais rien n'est
totalement certain on sait pas comment
la situation politique peut évoluer bon
disons que d'un point de vue du rapport
de force la logique évidemment y compris
par rapport à l'orientation politique
d'Emmanuel ecron ce serait une alliance
à explicite on va dire négocier avec les
républicains bon quitte à prendre le
risque certains républicains comme ça
s'est passé au moment de la réforme des
retraites rentrant dissidence ou quitte
ce parti mais on a vu qu'ils étaient
malgré tout minoritaire donc je dirais
que c'est c'est là que la seule voie de
sortie d'Emmanuel Macron pour essayer de
durer existe sauf que
évidemment il faut regarder la situation
électorale c'est-à-dire que beaucoup des
députés LR qui ont été élue en juin
dernier sont des députés qui ont face à
eux des candidats du rassemblement
national dans leur circonscriptions et
donc évidemment aller ouvertement
s'allier avec un président très affaibli
très impopulaire c'est prendre le risque
effectivement de ben voilà de perdre
l'élection on peut être sûr de son cours
l'alliance est plus facile à faire quand
on est en position de force et beaucoup
ont conserve quand même le sentiment que
Emmanuel Macron les a est un usurpateur
voilà et qu'il a marché ouvertement sur
le sur leur plate-bande et que voilà la
revanche viendra un jour et que s'allier
ouvertement dans ces conditions-là c'est
risqué effectivement de perdre sauf que
bon évidemment la montée en puissance du
rassemblement national peut
conduire aussi certains à se dire que
bon il faut essayer de se sauver à tout
prix donc je sais pas quelle va être le
calcul politique
il y a clairement une partie de LR qui
est quand même assez proche des idées
des positions du rassemblement national
une autre partie qui sans doute serait
prêt à soutenir peut-être je sais pas
moi Édouard Philippe ou etc mais c'est
quand même sur conditionné par les
conditions des circonscriptions
électorales dont sont issues le gros des
troupes de LR et
cette menace quand même sur eux d'une
concurrence là pour le coup voilà il
laisserait le champ libre en quelque
sorte
on est en train de de faire comme si
Elizabeth borne n'était déjà plus
première ministre alors Emmanuel Macron
lui a donné encore trois mois au minimum
l'impression qu'on a que ce 14 juillet
est finalement un espèce de contrat sur
la tête d'Elisabeth borne en lui en lui
laissant donc le temps de d'ouvrir cette
fameuse majorité de de proposer de
nouveaux résultats auraient même l'a dit
en quelque sorte étant donné que c'est
son job depuis le début de sa nomination
elle voit pas trop ce qu'elle va pouvoir
changer mais il y a il y a il y a en
effet sa propre musique quand même
relation président Premier ministre
toujours aussi cette espèce de brèche
qui fait que le premier ministre quand
il essaye d'exister alors peu parfois
gagner un petit peu cette bataille en
redonnant un petit peu de lustre à la
fonction ou au contraire complètement
perdre son crédit Michel Rocard Jacques
Chirac en fait à partir du moment où on
est plus vraiment sur le la du président
de la République et ben on n'a pas trop
le choix d'avoir un avenir politique la
question de savoir si finalement la
sortie de crise que nous vivons
actuellement pourra passer par un
remaniement à mon avis il me semble un
peu secondaire parce que le remaniement
le risque c'est toujours qu'il ressemble
un peu à un jeu de chaise musicale où on
remet un petit peu les mêmes à des
fonctions différentes à moins d'avoir
vraiment le vrai jeu du remaniement
c'est-à-dire de proposer un nouveau
contrat de gouvernance est-ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure sur les alliances
c'est que au fond une coalition ça ne se
décrète pas il faut créer les conditions
d'une coalition que ça soit en Allemagne
que ça soit n'importe où ce qu'on
appelle des contrats on peut reprendre
d'ailleurs l'exemple de Michel pas de
François Mitterrand à Michel
de François Mitterrand à l'époque où
justement et bien il y a les 100
propositions un vrai programme pour la
France donc si on veut véritablement
avoir un remaniement probant si il faut
que les quatre ans signent une nouvelle
méthode j'ai l'impression que le mot est
un peu éliminé mais un nouveau souffle
finalement et bien on se rend bien
compte que ça passera forcément par
quelque chose de bien plus négocié de
bien plus profond et c'est pareil
il faut une majorité un projet un
contrat c'est pareil que ce que dit
gérarchique c'est que au fond il y aller
dans ces conditions comme vous le disiez
c'est non seulement prendre le risque
d'être affilié à un naufrage mais en
plus c'est l'idée de ne pas forcément
savoir où l'on veuille je pense que
c'est ce qui cristallise beaucoup la
critique autour d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
que on n'est pas encore complètement
garanti d'avoir le cap de alors on a le
cap de ces trois mois mais on n'a pas
forcément le cap de ces quatre ans et ça
ça peut être un problème pour recomposer
des équipes et ludovicion il y a un
élément intéressant qui est un élément
institutionnel il faut remonter à la
révision concernée de 2008 on a beaucoup
parlé du 49 3 de la on va dire la
réduction du champ du 49-3 donc je vais
pas venir là-dessus mais sur le fait que
le président ne puisse être élu que deux
fois et ça ça change la donne
Macron le premier qui en fait
l'expérience on voit bien les effets les
conséquences que ça que ça a eu dès le
lendemain de sa réélection et il a tout
de suite incarné le passé il a 44 ans il
a il a déjà été vu comme un homme du
passé parce que effectivement le fait de
ne pas pouvoir se représenter à libérer
les ambitions au sein de sa famille ça
l'a rendu moins attractif ça l'a son
autorité a été un peu rognée il y a une
compte à rebours qui s'est immédiatement
mis en place même si même dans ça bien
sûr
mais ça doit jouer parce qu'on sait très
bien qui est manuel Macron a construit
un système où tout est centralisé autour
de sa personne ou tout est tourné autour
de lui et le fait que d'apparaître moins
puissant que son autorité soit
immédiatement contestée on l'a vu dans
l'histoire de la nomination de la
première ministre c'est quelque chose
qu'il vit forcément de manière délicate
forcément mal et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure mais il
faut peut-être revenir un peu en détail
il veut d'abord garder Jean Castex il
veut d'abord garder du fait de pas avoir
anticipé il veut d'abord regarder c'est
un moyen pour lui de se donner du temps
de se dire que bah peut-être que le
nouveau Premier ministre la nouvelle
Premier ministre je peux la nommer au
lendemain dès les élections législatives
et puis il a bien aimé travailler avec
Castex ça s'est bien passé il l'aimait
bien lors du haut il le trouvait
complémentaire mais j'encaisse ne veut
pas et donc à ce moment-là il se met à
la en recherche d'une femme une élue
locale qui vient plutôt de la droite et
Catherine Vautrin correspond à ces
critères là ça va loin dans la
discussion il se voit deux fois
une première fois une dizaine de jours
après la réélection de des manuel Macron
il se voit une heure dans le bureau du
chef de l'État il se connaissent très
peu donc c'est l'occasion pour eux de
faire un peu connaissance Emmanuel
Macron lui dit qu'il pense à elle pour
le poste de Premier ministre à la fin de
l'entretien il la charge de réfléchir à
une architecture gouvernementale au cas
où il ferait à faire et puis il a
reconvoque à l'Elysée semaine plus tard
nous sommes le jeudi 12 mai ils vont
déjeuner ensemble pendant trois heures
dans le dans le jardin et là Emmanuel
Macron va lui dire c'est vous que je
choisis et là ils vont parler de la
composition de l'équipe de la manière
dont ils vont travailler ensemble des
chantiers qu'ils vont ouvrir et à la fin
Brigitte Macron les rejoindra et
Emmanuel Macron lui présentera sa
nouvelle Première ministre et 4 jours
plus tard ce n'est pas elle et une élue
locale de droite est remplacée par une
techno de gauche effectivement c'est pas
exactement le même le même profil alors
vous avez parlé de l'âge de d'emman
Macron et on va y revenir tout de suite
avec vous Mathilde parce que c'est quand
même intéressant cette impossibilité de
se représenter ça fait qu'on se demande
déjà ce qu'il va faire après son second
quinquennat et pour trouver la réponse
vous regardez du côté de l'Allemagne et
oui Thomas puisque Emmanuel Macron
s'entend très bien avec l'ancienne
chancelière allemande Angela Merkel et
il arrive encore paraît-il que le
président et son ancienne homologue
communique encore et change des petits
messages par WhatsApp alors pourquoi
cette relation à son importance quand on
imagine la vie d'après pour Emmanuel
Macron Ludovic l'a dit Emmanuel Macron
est jeune il aura moins de 50 ans 49 ans
à la fin de son de son deuxième
quinquennat et il regarde en gala Merkel
pourquoi alors elle est beaucoup plus
âgée bien sûr mais elle est restée
longtemps aussi au pouvoir plus de 16
ans elle a quitté la vie publique et
politique depuis 15 mois il l'observe et
il voit il constate qu'elle est restée
depuis très discrète ce qui fait dire
aux proches du président qu'Emmanuel
Macron pourrait lui aussi de la même
manière observer ce qu'ils appellent à
un temps de pause un temps familial même
après 10 ans aux affaires ce qui
permettrait je cite encore des des
l'entourage Emmanuel Macron un temps de
décantation pour le pays Angela Merkel
de son côté là elle s'apprête à publier
ses mémoires peut-être que le chef de
l'État français aura lieu aussi envie de
faire la même chose pour l'instant il
paraît qu'il n'écrit pas donc tout ça
voilà c'est des éléments à prendre en
compte pour imaginer votre vie d'après
qui sera longue pour Emmanuel Macron
vit une seconde vie à reconstruire
ensuite une envie de revenir il ne peut
pas se représenter en 2027 mais
peut-être peut-être peut-il avoir en
2032 je pense qu'en revanche la Merkel
elle est définie la page de la politique
effectivement on a vu ça avec Nicolas
Sarkozy d'une certaine manière aussi
avec François Hollande il peut il peut
tenter de revenir en 2032 alors eux
n'ont pas réussi ça peut être justement
un élément de motivation pour Emmanuel
Macron encore un exploit à aller
chercher à mettre à son palmarès des
records mais pour envisager un retour
effectivement en 2032 qui lui sera
possible encore faut-il réussir sa
sortie en 2027 et son retour en 2032
dépend évidemment des circonstances de
son départ c'est à dire qu'une élection
de Marine Le Pen ou d'un représentant du
RN le disqualifierait politiquement
c'est ce que la macronie appelle le
syndrome Obama c'est à dire un président
un plutôt progressistes qui qui effectue
deux mandats successifs et qui à la fin
doit céder la place à une force
populiste ou une force extrême et qui le
contraint ensuite à renoncer à toute
responsabilité politique donc
effectivement on l'a vu sous la 5e c'est
très difficile d'envisager un retour ce
qu'on prête aussi à Emmanuel Macron pour
cet après qui reste très très flou très
nébuleux c'est peut-être des ambitions
internationales on a vu que l'Europe
c'était le marqueur de son identité
politique pourquoi pas envisager des
responsabilités à ce niveau là et plus
inédit Thomas certains voient dans
l'activisme du président à l'étranger à
l'international une volonté de décrocher
le prix Nobel alors là encore une
nouvelle campagne peut-être amenée en
tout cas il faut dire et Ludovic vigogne
l'a dit il a écrit aussi dans son livre
Les 100 jours cette perspective de la
près toute cette tout ce qu'elle charrie
comme incertitude est une source
supplémentaire voilà d'angoisse pour le
chef de l'État il en parle d'ailleurs
très peu et beaucoup n'osent même pas
lui en parler j'imagine ça doit pas être
pire
intéressant c'est ce que vous décriviez
c'est le le schéma institutionnel fait
que lui-même est dans cette réflexion et
nous commentateurs aussi Einstein
business si on regarde un peu dans le
rétroviseur de la 5e République Giscard
d'Estaing il avait 55 ans Nicolas
Sarkozy 57 bon il y a pas on n'a pas
d'équivalent d'un Président d'un ex
président aussi jeune quel rôle ont-ils
joué quel rôle pourrait-il jouer
Emmanuel Macron alors il y a déjà une
fonction qui s'est beaucoup démonétisée
c'est le rôle de
membres du Conseil constitutionnel il
faut le rappeler d'ailleurs les
présidents ont deux droits c'est à dire
que c'est une fonction à laquelle il
devra renoncer mais on sent bien ça ne
sera pas trop dans la personnalité du
personnage de de passer son temps là-bas
l'avenir européen me fait penser au
parallèle avec Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
justement parce que on fait beaucoup de
parallèles et je crois qu'en ce moment
on a on a raison de beaucoup comparer
Emmanuel Macron à Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing puisque il y a et cette même
frange de finalement de conservatisme et
de durcissement qui s'est installé à la
fin du mandat avec quelque chose qui
finalement était très contraire aux
progressisme qu'on pouvait avoir au
début et même une espèce de datonie un
petit peu par rapport à ce que l'homme
avait promis qui parfois font que les
deux hommes se ressemblent la l'amour de
ce projet européen étant en plus
totalement sincère et chevillé chez les
deux on pourrait envisager en effet que
que cette carrière existe
renouveler nos présidents de la
République c'est vrai que c'est une
problématique qu'on a pas trop eu à se
poser mais je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui se posera aussi avec nos
députés avec nos ministres c'est-à-dire
que plus on rajeunit la vie politique
lui il faut savoir que justement ces
questions de circulation dans une
société où en plus on regarde beaucoup
la transparence et où les questions de
pantouflage de passage d'un réseau à un
autre sont très contrôlés seront
sûrement des questions d'avenir et ça
nous apprendra peut-être à conjuguer
aussi la politique à d'autres temps
puisque
évidemment pas que le poste de Premier
ministre ou de président pour donner un
avenir on peut penser à des fonctions
des Luc locales on peut foncer on peut
penser à tout ce que finalement Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas eu le temps de faire dans
sa vie puisqu'il a été président très
tôt donc tout dépendra aussi de de sa
manière de voir son après la
reconversion est ouverte mais on a
encore 4 ans on a encore quatre ans on
va parler des ambitions internationales
d'Emmanuel Macron vous l'évoquez
Mathilde alors certains de ses voyages
provoquent des polémiques comme quand
ils rentrent de sa visite d'État en
Chine et qu'il affirme la pire des
choses serait de penser que nous
européens devront être suivis si par de
Taïwan sur ce sujet il nous adapter au
rythme américain et à une surréaction
chinoise quelques jours plus tard il
assume
la France est pour le statu quo à Taïwan
la France soutient la politique d'une
seule Chine et la recherche d'un
règlement pacifique de la situation
c'est d'ailleurs la position des
Européens
et c'est une position qui de tout temps
a été compatible avec le rôle d'allier
mais c'est justement là que j'insiste
sur l'importance de l'autonomie
stratégique être alliée ne signifie pas
être face à ce qu'on est allié qu'on
fait des choses ensemble qu'on décide de
faire qu'on a plus le droit de penser
tout seul
l'influence internationale d'un email
Macron est-ce que les difficultés
intérieures
fragilisent finalement sont son
influence sur la scène européenne ou sur
la scène internationale c'est sûr que
quand on est lis la presse
internationale et les réactions aussi
des officiels après à la fois son voyage
en Chine mais il faudrait remonter aussi
aux prises de position d'Emmanuel Macron
sur l'Ukraine et les tentatives assez
désespérées de maintenir une relation
avec Poutine l'image s'est
considérablement dégradée alors
pas aux yeux de tous
on a vu que sur la Chine Marine Le Pen
aussi bien que une partie de la France
insoumise
tout à fait applaudit la position de
Macron et à l'étranger aussi j'ai à dire
des forces très souverainistes ou très
très radical à gauche avait plus ancien
ou anti-américaine par anti-américanisme
quand il utilise comme le terme de
vassal pour qu'elle sous-entendu
les pays qui s'alignent dans le cadre de
l'OTAN sur les États-Unis sont des pays
vassaux des États-Unis
ça fait plaisir à certaines oreilles
mais enfin on imagine quand même les
mois dans les dans les dans les
diplomaties disons européennes de
manière générale donc là
s'il veut gagner le prix Nobel de la
paix je sais pas très très bien comment
il va s'y prendre parce que
la crédibilité disons de la France il
était très bien vu quand il a été élu en
2017 vu comme un président jeune qui est
qui est effectivement pas pris dans des
carcans idéologiques assez pragmatique
très pro-européen et
là-dessus on peut pas dire quand même y
compris sur le dossier européen qui
tient très à coeur que il est beaucoup
de succès à mettre à son actif enfin bon
voilà quand on discute avec les
principaux de parlementaires européen
différents pays on voit bien que
l'Allemagne continue d'être très très
beaucoup plus influente que la France
bien que un gala Merkel soit plus haute
commande et donc il a pas vraiment
réussi à
récupérer un peu de l'influence
française et du rayonnement français
dans les instituts européennes donc
franchement son bilan international ça
grave et on voit pas très très bien
comment disons sur quel dossier il
pourrait en quelque sorte apparaître
comme un des grands leaders de de ce
monde Ludovic qu'est-ce qu'il motive
vraiment aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron
il est quand même il est quand même là
encore pour 4 ans et il sait que à la
fin il doit quand même laisser une trace
avoir un bilan
et ça un président qui a dans un
deuxième mandat forcément ça en tête
donc il a déjà cette cette ambition là
ensuite je pense qu'Emmanuel Macron il
veut retisser un lien avec les Français
il est comme tous les autres présidents
depuis 48 heures c'est deux déplacements
il veut il a envie d'être populaire et
donc c'est ce qui va s'employer à faire
dans les dans les mois qui viennent donc
à la fois il y a des deux facettes là
ils s'ennuient pas un peu de temps en
temps je crois que ça va mieux je pense
que la le fait que la loi sur les
retraites ait été promulguées la
soulager il était impatient de passer à
autre chose ce qui est en revanche ce
qui est sûr c'est que les premiers jours
de son mandat ont pu l'ennuyer un peu
car il a dû refaire des choses qu'il
avait déjà faites et qui le passionne
pas vraiment nommé un gouvernement un
premier ministre c'est pas des choses
qui qui le passionne absolument il est
plus dans la gestion et dans le fait de
mener à bien des dossiers compliqués il
est en train de saturer l'espace
médiatique s'intéressant uncharen bizina
là depuis 48 heures c'est peut-être la
c'est pas nouveau mais ça des des aires
de campagne électorales
au cœur je sais pas s'il va pouvoir
faire ça pendant 4 ans mais c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant ce changement de
portée finalement on a eu le sentiment
qu'il y avait un retranchement à
l'Élysée pendant pendant ce moment de la
séquence retraite et que là au contraire
le besoin de proximité se fait
complètement sentir presque de manière
un peu exagérée au fond est-ce que l'un
est là pour faire passer l'autre c'est
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
que peut-être Emmanuel Macron et ça a
été de passer du beau mais finalement
sur sa relation sociale sociétale avec
les citoyens et bon cette méthode
directe est quand même toujours la plus
indiquée pour justement et bien être ce
qu'on appelle à portée de baffe pour nos
mini pour nos mères donc pourquoi pas
l'appliquer un président néanmoins je
suis pas sûr non plus que ce soit
forcément une posture très épanou contre
pour un président de la République
puisque au fond la posture initiale qui
consiste à se retrancher et quand même
bien plus dans la fonction c'est-à-dire
que on voit mal le président continué
comme ça à aller sur les marchés tractés
pour sa personne ça fait quand même pas
partie de son boulot et donc je pense
que c'est essentiellement une une
posture de voilà de dialogue il essaye
de renouer d'image aussi peut-être qu'il
essaie de de casser un petit peu par
rapport à ce caractère Brigitte Macron
l'a fait il y a quelques jours hein ce
caractère isolé en disant non mon mari
n'est pas isolé il entend tout à fait la
parole des autres et donc je pense que
c'est vraiment cette image là qu'il est
en train d'essayer de casser est-ce que
sur l'avenir il continuera sur cette
gouvernance ça n'est quand même pas
garanti que ce soit vous le voyez
continuer c'est ce qui a plus ou moins
été annoncé chaque semaine il y aura un
ou deux déplacements etc ou alors il va
être rattrapé par la tentation de des
voyages beaucoup plus lointains je pense
qu'il veut montrer qu'il n'est pas
bunkérisé qu'il peut sortir qu'il peut
aller à la rencontre du pays que ce
n'est pas tout le pays qui est en colère
contre lui qu'il y a encore des Français
qui peuvent l'aimer le saluer et lui
parler calmement donc c'est très
important
je pense et il est important y compris
psychologiquement voilà de montrer qu'il
n'y a pas de de rupture absolue avec le
pays il y a une forme de courage
politique est-ce que vous lui
reconnaissez ça d'aller au contact des
français Nicolas Sarkozy le faisait
beaucoup moins par exemple à chaque fois
des centaines voire des milliers de CRS
pour le protéger donc bon il y a un
courage c'est un peu comme chercher oui
enfin il est il est apporté l'engueulade
oui bien sûr il y a une façon peut-être
cathartique là mais enfin très
honnêtement
quand on regarde en tout cas les
enquêtes opinions et je passe simplement
les réactions des Français avec les
casseroles ça ça crédibilité c'est
considérablement effondré l'enquête de
l'ifope qui est sorti hier montre que
les Français même aujourd'hui ne lui
reconnaissent plus la majoritairement la
compétence était le grand
disons le grand atout de montrer en
première partie de sondage je sais pas
si on l'a toujours
une manette mais si vous le retrouvez on
peut le retenir
je suis courageux c'est genre c'est
plutôt perçu comme je je me fiche un peu
du monde c'est-à-dire je n'écoute pas et
ensuite je mets en scène une fausse
écoute hein voilà je suis donc donc je
suis je pense que c'est plutôt
interprété comme d'abord de la
provocation et de d'un sur orgueil en
quelque sorte de sa part et ça n'est pas
du tout en plus raccord avec cette idée
qu'il pourrait gouverner autrement
collectivement parce que ces gens c'est
moi tout seul quand il y avait plus de
mini c'est plus le Premier ministre j'y
vais seul enfin bon c'est un peu moi
personnellement je pense que
l'efficacité de de la stratégie j'aurais
peut-être pu attendre un peu et plutôt
que d'aller comme ça de façon un peu
provocatrice quoi c'est ça peut être
aussi à mon avis plutôt interpréter
comme ça donc bon voilà je je sais pas
si c'est du enfin pour moi c'est pas du
courage le courage aurait été bien plus
de d'accepter d'écouter de concerté et
de ne pas être dans cette posture très
très autoritaire qui a été la sienne
pendant ces derniers mois de cette
émission merci beaucoup merci à tous d'y
avoir participé Ludovic vigogne je
rappelle le titre de votre livre les 100
jours Macron les secrets d'un passage à
vide chez bouquin édition voilà c'est la
fin de ce sens public je vous dis à
lundi et on parlera tiens toujours et
encore des coulisses de la vie politique
demain dans la matinale Oriane mansini
reçoit Gilles Boyer et Cédric Le Bihan
les auteurs de la BD dans l'ombre belle
soirée à toutes et à tous salut
[Musique]